sometimes a taste of home is enough to
ease the pain of being homesick other
times you don't realize how delicious
American food is until it's no longer an
option wait and tell our number one to
see white Doritos is the best example of
food you might seriously miss if you're
traveling if this is your first time
visiting the things don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up here are 10 strange foods
you wouldn't be able to buy in other
countries cereal cereal is always a
comforting meal whether it be an early
morning energy boost or a late night
meal however if you travel to places in
Europe or Australia you might be
disappointed that some cereal staples
like Captain Crunch or Lucky Charms
cannot be purchased at your local
grocery stores however since 2014 a
serial killer cafe was opened and offers
a variety of over 100 cereals from
around the world available for purchase
for breakfast lunch or dinner strict
health regulations in Australia
prevented the sale of fruit loops due to
artificial color and flavors instead
they devised a healthier version
Kellogg's plans on revisiting it's
classic cereal recipes to make them
healthier peanut butter sometimes it
takes not having access to something in
order to realize how much you love it
that's definitely the case for anyone
who has lived in the 10 countries that
don't sell peanut butter among the list
are countries such as France Italy Spain
Russia and China even if you do manage
to find a stash of peanut butter on the
back shelf of the European grocery store
it likely won't be your go-to brand nor
would it provide you with the options we
have grown used to preferred chunky or
smooth you might just have to make do
with what you find if you're living or
traveling abroad barbecue sauce
summertime means barbecues and a good
old-fashioned cookout is never complete
without copious amounts of barbecue
sauce it's appropriate that a condiment
is so iconic ly American since it turns
ribs into a mouth-watering irresistible
dish though some of us might take it for
granted a life without barbecue sauce is
a bland one so the Kansas City barbecue
society has done its part to introduce
an American favourite into European
cuisine valdon now hosts a barbecue
festival accompanied by fresh Belgium
beer we can only hope Europeans will
begin to realize a flavor
they've been missing out on and will
take on a food tradition representative
of American culture old El Paso old El
Paso's original mission was to make
Mexican cuisine mainstream in America
and it has exceeded as it is now the
second most consumed ethnic food in the
United States sitting behind Italian
from stand up shells canned salsa and
pinto beans to squeezable bottles of
guacamole old El Paso has slowly made
its way into French and Australian
markets if you're in Asia some parts of
Europe are even Africa you will have a
tough time finding any Mexican cuisine
at all though it has secured its
culinary spot across the border old El
Paso still has some ways to go if it
wants to be known as an international
brand cheese's this snack is a
quintessential in any American kids
lunchbox crunchy like a chip but with a
cheesy deliciousness of real cheese we'd
be lying if we didn't admit to some
serious cheese at cravings every now and
again unfortunately if you find yourself
abroad if this familiar snack will be
difficult or even impossible to find
however if you find yourself in
Australia your cravings might be
appeased by an interesting substitution
called pizza shapes this snack is like a
mix between Pepperidge Farm goldfish and
cheeses they even share cheese it's
square shape and come in a multitude of
flavors Kraft Dinner macaroni and cheese
whether your memories of caviar as a
child in college as an adult or let's be
honest all of the above it's no surprise
that this classic and quick box mille
lacs the nutrients necessary for a
healthy lifestyle nevertheless it's a
quick fix and easy go to that we all
crave at one point or another other
countries however have banned two of the
food dyes in khaidi yellow 5 and yellow
6 because it triggers severe and
potentially chronic allergic reactions
in children this is not to say that it's
impossible to find a box of Kady in a
foreign grocery store but it won't have
that recognizable taste we just love to
hate graham crackers and s'mores we're
willing to bet that if we asked you to
make a camping list graham crackers our
s'mores would be one of the first items
you grab that delicious combination of
graham crackers marshmallow and
chocolate is a staple any American child
learns from family camping trips or
summer camp bonfires however if you're
living in Australia you'll have to
settle for digestive cookies
as a replacement for the honey taste of
graham crackers graham crackers crumbs
don't even exist in the UK or Australia
so the base of a cheesecake will have to
be made from scratch or with a
replacement cookie pop-tarts pop-tarts
were created in the 1960s and have taken
America by storm
creating over 30 different flavors that
could be easily heated in a toaster
however if you go abroad hoping to find
your favorite pop tart flavor at a local
grocery store you might end up very
disappointed even just north of the
border Canada sells less than a third of
the flavors offered on the shelves of US
grocery stores both the US and London
have attempted to accommodate new
healthy trends offering a healthy
alternative to be served at cafes do you
think it's worth it to go healthy with
pop-tarts or is this some American snack
that needs to be left as is corn dogs as
far as American meals on-the-go the corn
dog is definitely a classic great at
barbecues fairs or sports events corn
dogs are a familiar taste to all
Americans whether you choose to dunk it
in mustard or ketchup corn dogs are
deeply embedded in the American
fast-food tradition it was first
patented in 1927 and is a somewhat
healthy junk food option as the average
calorie count for each corndog is
approximately 225 calories though corn
dogs are much harder to find elsewhere
in the world they have become popular in
certain regions of New Zealand Japan and
South Korea a sushi crossbred has even
become a success Dorito flavors Doritos
made our number-one not just because of
its history as the first-ever nacho chip
but because of the global transformation
and has undergone from a maxim cover of
an astronaut holding the bag of Doritos
on the moon Doritos have been a major
part of what it means to be American
what makes this snack our number one is
the fact that though some American
flavors are hard to find around the
globe some countries like Japan have
really made it their own renaming Cool
Ranch flavor to cool American with
flavors like wasabi mayo sausage fried
chicken and fondue just to name a couple
Japan has run with the
d of eccentric Dorito flavors have you
gone abroad and missed a particular
American food let us know in the
comments and that's all for the ten
strange foods you wouldn't be able to
buy another country's make sure to like
this video and subscribe to the things
to catch more videos like this thanks
for watching
[Music]